triumph für boris johnson der
konservative premier gewinnt die wahl in
großbritannien und will ende januar raus
aus der eu
große pläne fürs klima die eu will bis
2050 klimaneutral werden lässt aber
ausnahmen zu für polens kohle und länder
mit atomkraft bruchlandung für den
bundesliga überflieger borussia
mönchengladbach scheiterte in letzter
minute in der europa league
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und nahmen den an
diesem freitag 13
dezember hier ist ihr
nachrichtenüberblick und kristin otto
steuert nachher den sport man habe
einiges an bord guten abend der große
wahlsieger in großbritannien heißt boris
johnson seine konservativen haben jetzt
die absolute mehrheit im parlament
und das wiederum heißt der weg für den
bhc rexit dürfte jetzt frei sein
schauen wir uns mal die britischen
zeitungsschlagzeilen heute an jubel
boris stürmt zum erdrutsch sieg daily
mail der daily telegraph schreibt
johnsons historischer sieg und bei der
sun ein echter britischer ausdruck
übersetzt etwa das beste überhaupt in
nüchternen zahlen sieht der klare
wahlsieg von johnson so aus von den 650
wahlkreisen haben die konservativen 365
gewonnen
die labour-partei von jeremy kolben holt
nur 203 sitze das ist die absolute
mehrheit für johnson reaktionen und
einzelheiten jetzt aus london von
andreas stamm
manchen steht der schock ins gesicht
geschrieben labour anhänger praxis
gegner die gehofft hatten auf eine
überraschung die ausblieb bolls johnsons
konservative dagegen in freuten wir
werden endlich den dreck sind durch zehn
ihr habt gut aufgepasst
der premier auch am nachmittag noch mehr
als euphorisch wir stellen eine
volksregierung wir haben wahlkreise
geholt die die konservativen 100 jahre
nicht gewonnen haben durch ein klares
versprechen dass wir beherzigen werden
bis zum 31 januar der eu austritt
erledigen
ein triumph so nur möglich aufgrund des
mehrheitswahlrechts
obwohl johnsons konservative nicht mal
zwei prozent mehr holen als 2017
deutlich unter 50 prozent liegen
reicht es für eine satte absolute sitz
mehrheit im parlament doch die spaltung
des landes in brax it gegner und
befürworter ist geblieben
ich bin sauer kann nicht glauben dass
wir so gewählt haben ich habe die ganze
nacht geweint
das ist überzeugend er liebt das land
wird uns aus der eu führen jeder hat die
nase voll vom brh exit wir wollen nach
vorne schauen
die wahl entschieden hat das thema exit
oppositionsführer corbijn wollte ein
zweites referendum das lehnte ein großer
teil traditioneller labour wähler ab von
denen viele ihn auch nicht als premier
wollte ich werde die partei führen bis
ein neuer vorsitzender gewählt ist dann
zurücktreten
boris johnson wird dagegen intern
downing street von seinem team
beglückwünscht glück dass er brauchen
wird für die zeit nach dem offiziellen
austritt für die verhandlungen über die
künftigen beziehungen mit der eu
kurze analyse jetzt zunächst mit diana
zimmermann für uns in london diana guten
abend was hat johnson am ende diesen
sieg beschert erstens erschöpfung die
meisten briten sind der brekzie
diskussion mit der slogan von boris
johnson den wechsel durchziehen hat er
sehr verführerisch gewirkt zweitens der
gegenkandidat für boris johnson hat
jeremy corbijn leichte beute die meisten
briten erkennen denn ihm keine
führungspersönlichkeit und dritten
skrupellosigkeit das konservative
wahlkampfteam hat offensichtliche lügen
verbreitet es hat interviews von
oppositionspolitikern verfälscht online
gestellt es hat eigene wahlkampf infos
als fact checker ausgegeben kurzum sie
haben beschlossen dass für ihren
heiligen zweck jedes mittel recht ist so
auf jeden fall einen wahlkampf der
nachdenklich machte diana wir sollten
noch aus schottland gucken heute abend
da haben die schottischen nationalisten
enorm abgeräumt und wollen jetzt ein
neues referendum über ihre
unabhängigkeit wie einig ist das
vereinigte königreich nach dieser wahl
es ist nicht einig wir sind dieselbe
spaltung die wir schon beim referendum
gesehen haben england und wales haben
damals für den exit gestimmte nordirland
und schottland dagegen
und jetzt haben nordirland und
schottland diese wendung hin zu den
konservativen nicht mitgemacht sondern
nationalistisch gestimmt dass verstärkt
natürlich die fliehkräfte im land und es
wird so boris johnson großen aufgaben
gehören das land irgendwie zusammen zu
halten
das war die lage in großbritannien diana
vielen dank und dann gucken wir uns
jetzt mal an wie es jetzt weitergeht in
sachen drexhage boris johnson will
seinen braig citydeal noch vor
weihnachten vom unterhaus absegnen
lassen
das dürfte mit der neuen klaren mehrheit
unproblematisch funktionieren dann 31
januar das ist der termin an dem
großbritannien die eu verlassen wird
ohne wenn und aber sagte der premier
danach beginnt eine übergangsphase bis
ende 2020 in der beide seiten ihre
künftigen beziehungen aber noch
aushandeln müssen
und da liegt der teufel im detail anne
gellinek in brüssel guten abend auch
nach brüssel die eu und großbritannien
die verhandeln
bisher schon aber da ging es um die
vergangenheit jetzt geht es um die
zukunft wird das aus sicht der eu ein
braig cit der ohne probleme durch läuft
nein einfach wird leider auch in der
nächsten phase nichts die briten wollen
ja gerade deshalb aus der eu austreten
weil sie nicht mehr gewillt sind die
regeln die für alle im europäischen
binnenmarkt für alle 28 gelten diese
regeln wollen sie nicht mehr akzeptieren
und deshalb wird man alle möglichen
bereiche neu verhandeln werden
verhandeln müssen ob es die zoll die
zölle anbetrifft die umweltstandards
fischereirechte oder auch die den
datenaustausch bei der gemeinsamen
terrorabwehr über all das wird man noch
einmal reden müssen und experten sagen
bereits jetzt schon dass dafür die elf
monate doch reichlich knapp sind klappen
kann das eigentlich nur wenn sich die
briten weiterhin ganz eng an
eu-standards anlehnen was dann wieder
die frage aufwirft warum sie dann
überhaupt austreten wollen also fakt ist
der 31 januar das austritts datum ist
nicht das ende sondern der beginn einer
neuen etappe der britisch europäischen
beziehungen einer etappe die offenbar
nicht einfacher wird viel zu tun an
vielen dank und wir bleiben noch einen
moment in brüssel ohne die briten hatten
die 27 eu-regierungen bis tief in die
nacht um ein gemeinsames klimaziel
gerungen
die einigung nannte kanzlerin angela
merkel einen meilenstein europa
klimaneutral bis 2050
doch der weg dahin ist noch nicht klar
nicht alle machen aus überzeugung mit
polen bestand auf einer ausnahmeklausel
und bekamen sie auch gunnar krüger
ursula von der leyen will einen
kontinent mit ausgeglichener klimabilanz
und das um drei jahrzehnten dafür hat
sie eine staats- und regierungschefs
hinter sich jedenfalls beinahe ich bin
unter den gegebenen umständen ehrlich
gesagt recht zufrieden denn wenn man mal
ein jahr zurück denken da war von
klimaneutralität 2050 noch überhaupt gar
nicht die rede
das ist jetzt anders was den energiemix
zum thema macht der schwankt von
mitgliedstaat zu mitgliedstaat
polen hängt zu 80 prozent am
klimaschädlichen kohlestrom sein premier
erhält beim gipfel deshalb einen
aufschub muss aber bis juni nach besser
wenn polen am ende nichts sagen so wie
es für dem ziel beitragen will dann
erhält es auch keine finanzielle hilfe
aus europa
denn das ist die frage wer bekommt wie
viel für den energieumbau was ist
klimafreundlich was ist förderfähig
tschechien fordert auch die kernkraft
müsse dazu gehören selbst finnland das
im rat der eu die präsidentschaft hat
baut gerade ein neues kraftwerk wir
stehen voll hinter dem ziel der
klimaneutralität sagt die neue
regierungschefin wir wollen dass sogar
bis 2035 schaffen
atomstrom als saubere energiequelle
einzustufen diese forderung aber
schaffte es nicht ins abschlusspapier
zwei wichtige nachrichten heute aus den
usa zunächst das amtsenthebungsverfahren
gegen präsident donald trump da wird es
jetzt ernst voraussichtlich schon in der
nächsten woche wird das us
repräsentantenhaus über die
anklagepunkte abstimmen der
justizausschuss der parlamentskammer hat
sie heute abgesegnet
die vorwürfe lauten machtmissbrauch und
behinderung der ermittlungen des
kongresses nach der abstimmung im
repräsentantenhaus geht das verfahren
dann im senat weiter dort haben trumps
republikaner die mehrheit
und dann der handelsstreit mit china
da hat sich us-präsident trump zuletzt
ja widersprüchlich geäußert
jetzt verkündete eine teileinigung und
verzichtet auf strafzölle gegen china in
letzter minute sozusagen ab diesem
sonntag wollten die usa eigentlich
zusätzliche abgaben verlangen auf
konsumartikel wie laptops und
smartphones
jetzt will trump auch bereits verhängte
zölle teilweise wieder zurücknehmen und
da guckt mal dieser stelle in die
deutsche politik gibt es neue spannende
zahlen vom zdf politbarometer die spd
erhofft sich einen neustart mit neuem
chef durch die frage an matthias fornoff
guten namens kommt er an bei den
deutschen
ein schwungvoller neuanfang denn der
sieht jedenfalls anders aus skeptisch
ist der blick aufs neue spd
spitzenpersonal saskia esken und norbert
walter borjans können die spd nicht
erfolgreich in die zukunft führen
das erwartet eine klare mehrheit von 62
prozent
und das sehen wir hier rechts sogar 42
prozent der spd anhänger teilen diese
negativ prognose die sozialdemokraten
sind nach links gerückt ihre forderung
nach mehr staatlichen investitionen auch
wenn dafür mehr schulden gemacht werden
die kommt gut an
drei viertel unterstützen das
mehrheitlich die anhänger aller parteien
sogar von union und fdp
und könnte die spd profitieren wenn am
sonntag bundestagswahl wäre
nein die spd verharrt auf ihrem
tiefstand wenn am sonntag bundestagswahl
wäre käme die union auf 27 prozent die
spd auf 13
afg 14 alle unverändert fdp 8 plus 1
linke 9 minus 1 grüne 23 prozent
unverändert das würde reichen für
schwarz grün nicht aber für grün rot rot
und jetzt macht er jetzt vielleicht ein
bisschen generelles thema manchmal hat
man ja in deutschland den eindruck die
stimmung könnte durchaus besser sein da
ist auch viel unzufriedenheit zu hören
dass geben aber interessanterweise deine
zahlen nicht die absolut so sieht's aus
ist es besser als man so denken könnte
denn drei viertel der deutschen sagen
2009 10 war ein gutes jahr für mich
22 prozent fanden ist schlecht 2020 wird
noch besser
das erwartet fast jeder dritte ein
optimistischer blick nach vorn also tut
gut
willberg klavier und alle nachrichten
alle informationen zum politbarometer
natürlich heute abend eben heute journal
und auch online bei heute de und in der
heute app unser nächstes thema jetzt das
problem drängt schon länger dass ich
denke jetzt kommt der gesetzentwurf oder
ja ok sehr gut jetzt gibt es einen
entwurf für ein gesetz dass hass und
hetze im internet eindämmen soll
und da gucken wir uns mal den
der sieht so aus eine meldepflicht für
plattformen wie facebook oder twitter
sie müssen künftig strafbare inhalte
nicht nur löschen sondern auch dem bka
melden volksverhetzung morddrohungen
etwa gegen politiker oder
kinderpornographie melden die betreiber
diese taten nicht dann drohen bußgelder
bis zu 50 millionen euro um die fälle
bearbeiten zu können sollen hunderte
neue ermittler eingestellt werden mehr
personal fordert auch die justiz und
verabschiedet verabschiedet hat der
bundestag heute eingesetzt dass das
waffenrecht verschärft die
regierungsparteien wollen so für mehr
sicherheit sorgen
wer eine waffe will soll künftig immer
vom verfassungsschutz überprüft werden
das ziel sagt innenminister horst
seehofer keine waffen in die hände von
terroristen und die bundesländer können
an belebten orten und rund um schulen
zonen einrichten in denen waffen und
messer
verboten sind ein toter und mindestens
15 verletzte das ist die vorläufige
bilanz nach einer schweren explosion in
einem mehrfamilienhaus in blankenburg in
sachsen-anhalt
ursache ist vermutlich eine gasexplosion
den ermittler fanden in der wohnung des
toten mehrere flaschen mit flüssiggas
einsatzkräfte evakuierten den bereich
die kriminalpolizei ermittelt jetzt ob
die explosion absichtlich ausgelöst
wurde
unser nächstes thema pflege für alte und
behinderte frauenhäuser kindergärten ein
soziales netz das ist es im kern was die
arbeiterwohlfahrt bietet und das jetzt
seit genau 100 jahren gegründet wurde
die awo aus dem umfeld der spd
heute arbeiten mehr als 230.000
mitarbeiter und nochmal gut 73.000
ehrenamtliche bei der awo auch viele von
ihnen allerdings reiben sich die augen
über die schlagzeilen von der awo in
hessen dort ermittelt die
staatsanwaltschaft wegen betrugs und
untreueverdacht 100 jahre awo die
jubiläumsfeier ist nicht ganz
unbeschwert dominik löschmeister
berichtet festakt der arbeiterwohlfahrt
in berlin der bundespräsident dank
mitarbeitern und
ehrenamtlichen dafür den zusammenhalt in
der gesellschaft zu stärken
100 jahre arbeiterwohlfahrt das sind 100
jahre gelebte solidarität ich wünsche
mir dass ihr verband auch in zukunft ein
ort bleibt an dem unsere gesellschaft in
ihrer ganzen vielfalt zusammenkommt die
feier in berlin überschattet von einer
affäre der awo kreisverbände in
frankfurt und wiesbaden die
staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt es geht um
veruntreuung von öffentlichen zuschüssen
hinzukommen überhöhte gehälter teure
dienstwagen so war jürgen richter
geschäftsführer der awo in frankfurt
seine frau hannelore lange zeit in der
gleichen position in wiesbaden beide
hatten jeweils funktionen im anderen
verband nach dem ausschalten der mutter
übernahm der sohn deren posten in
wiesbaden dass hier in dieser form und
in dieser intensität familiäre
beziehungen ausgenutzt werden um
miteinander geschäfte zu machen über
diese organisationen
das ist höchst ungewöhnlich und man
fragt sich warum das niemand verhindert
hat ehrenamtliche sind fassungslos hier
sollte morgen die weihnachtsfeier des
ortsverbandes frankfurt nied stattfinden
nun ist alles abgesagt wir machen hier
viel für kinder und natürlich für
senioren überhaupt keine frage
und das ist ein schlag ins gesicht der
awo bundesverband sieht einen immensen
imageschaden verspricht aufklärung es
gehört wie ich finde auch zur
solidarität in der arbeiterwohlfahrt
auch gegenüber denjenigen die unter
solchen verfehlungen zu leiden haben
dass wir alles tun um es aufzuklären
denn die affäre schade den vielen
ehrenamtlichen und mitarbeitern der awo
die sich seit 100 jahren für schwache in
der gesellschaft einsetzen
vom chef zur persona non grata in
österreich lässt eine
personalentscheidung aufhorchen
die rechte fpö hat heinz christian
strache aus der partei geworfen
zuletzt war der ehemalige vorsitzende
und vizekanzler in mehrere skandale
verwickelt er plant jetzt offenbar ein
comeback in einer neuen partei strache
wurde vor allem das sogenannte ibiza
video zum verhängnis heimlich gemachte
aufnahmen zeigen ihn darin empfänglich
für korruption
musste im mai von allen ämtern
zurücktreten die fdp büßte bei neuwahlen
stimmen ein so und damit sind wir in
dieser sendung an diesem freitag dem 13
beim sport christin zackig weiter mit
fußball europa league neben leverkusen
stehen auch wolfsburg und frankfurt in
der zwischenrunde mega frust dagegen bei
borussia mönchengladbach 1 2 gegen bayer
aktie istanbul ein last minute aus für
den bundesliga-spitzenreiter national
ein titelkandidat international
bedeutungslos die bittere erkenntnis
eines abends der zunächst nach plan
verlief die hereingabe von lima kamen
durch zu tür am gladbacher führung nach
einer halben stunde hielt bis zur 44
minute bis zu diesem folgenschweren
fehler von torwart sommer nachschuss von
chan der beginn von gladbachs pleite
passiert halt macht mir jetzt keinen
vorwurf dem lande hat uns auch oft genug
geredet
ja ist aber trotzdem bitter für für alle
heute ein unentschieden hätte zum
gruppensieg gereicht stattdessen der
siegtreffer für die türken durch
crivelli heimniederlage trotz
überlegenen spiels nach dem dfb pokal
der zweite wettbewerb ohne
mönchengladbach das tut weh jürgen klopp
hat seinen vertrag beim champions league
gewinner fc liverpool vorzeitig
verlängert bis 2024
der frühere meistertrainer von borussia
dortmund coach den souveränen
tabellenführer der premier league seit
gut vier jahren
große enttäuschung bei den deutschen
handballerinnen zum abschluss der
weltmeisterschaft in japan durch die
niederlage gegen schweden im spiel um
platz sieben haben sie auch keine chance
mehr bei olympia in tokio dabei zu sein
es ist vorbei das bittere ende einer wm
die so gut begonnen hatte nur ein punkt
fehlte zum halbfinaleinzug das spiel
gegen schweden fast ein spiegelbild der
in deutschland zu beginn stark 8 zu 4
die führung
für eine viertelstunde zeit und energie
die wir gebraucht haben unserem spiel zu
gewinnen sondern was weg wir haben vorne
keine tore mehr geworfen wir waren in
der abwehr nicht aggressiv genug
schon zur halbzeit lagen die schwedinnen
vorne siegten letztlich souverän 35 zu
24 ein debakel für deutschland damit
wurde die qualifikation für olympia
verpasst zum dritten mal nacheinander
echt schade stimmt wenn christian beim
wetter bleibt spannend und gefährlich
zugleich heute nacht noch glatte straßen
morgen wenig schnee viel regen details
gleich von katja honnefer das heute
journal mit der kollegin marietta slomka
um 22 uhr wir sind morgen am samstag
wieder für sie daran zwar sehr gerne
bis dann und vorher noch in einen
angenehmen abend
[Musik]
meine damen und herren heute gab es ja
häufig schnee und schnee sogar auf den
autobahnen jetzt aber wird es spannend
von west mit einem sturm das geht schon
um mitternacht los über frankreich und
dann wird dieses sturmfeld über die
eifel und den thüringer wald morgen bis
zum erzgebirge ziehen aber auch am
dritten advent also am sonntag bleibt es
stürmisch zumindest an den küsten da
sind durchaus noch windböen bis 90
kilometer pro stunde drin
heute nacht wird erstmal wieder glatt
besonders in den mittelgebirgen die
schneefallgrenze liegt ungefähr bei 600
meter und auch im nordosten kann es
gefährlich glatt werden wenn der regen
auf gefrorenen boden fällt
sonst bleibt die nacht etwas milder und
morgen erwarten uns dann
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 4 grad zum
beispiel im vogtland und elf grad am
oberrhein und das wird ein sehr
stürmischer und regnerischer samstag in
den mittelgebirgen ist auch noch schnee
dabei am sonntag ändert sich was denn
besonders am nachmittag kann sich dann
hier zwischen der elbe und dem emsland
häufiger die sonne zeigen da ruft der
stürmische wind die wolken einfach
auseinander
da gibt es da noch so schauerwetter im
süden bleibt es dagegen stärker bewölkt
und regnerisch
in der nächsten woche geht es mit weiter
bis zu 15 grad am dienstag späten abend
noch